Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie. So Agents
of S.H.I.E.L.D. is back tonight so I thought I'd do
a refresher video on the Inhumans. The back
half of Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. Season 2
is gonna be all about explaining who
their culture, their society are.
The Inhumans that you see in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, in the TV shows, in the movies,
are gonna be a little bit different from
what they are in the comics so I'll try to
explain what the difference is.
But I'm gonna start with their original
origin story from the comics. They suffer
from the same problem that a lot of big
Marvel characters have.
They belong to a group of people whose
origin is tied to
another group that Marvel no longer has
the IP for, for
the films and TV shows. So let's get
started. The characters were created by Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby, so totally expect a
Stan Lee cameo in 2019, whenever the movie comes.
They appeared for the first time in Fantastic Four #45.
In that issue Stan Lee introed most of who
would become
the Royal Family, but at the time the
Inhumans were just these few characters.
There was Black Bolt, Crystal, Medusa,
Gorgon, Karnak, Lockjaw
and Triton. The plot of some of those early
Stan Lee stories was kinda whimsical but
it was the swinging sixties, which I know
sounds kinda like a Spider-Man joke, but
you get the idea. You know, the characters
were really interesting
but sometimes some of the story beats
were a little bit funny.
So the first time we see them Johnny
Storm is getting stood up for a date
and as he's grumbling his way walking
back to the Baxter Building
he sees a mysterious redhead in an
alleyway who turns out to be Crystal.
Mystified, he tries to follow her, shows
her his powers in an alleyway
which isn't a euphemism for pulling his
pants down. If he did that today he would
totally get arrested.
"Let's go to this dark alleyway and I'll
show you something really special."
Crystal reveals that she also has
special powers, introduces her special dog, Lockjaw,
he opens a portal and Crystal takes
Johnny Storm to her home.
Nowadays this would be a story that
parents would show their kids to tell them
why you don't go home with strangers. So
Johnny Storm gets to see
Attilan for the first time, that's the
Inhuman's secret city that's cloaked from view.
Across their history in the comics
it's moved around in terms of its
location relative to Earth but
initially it started on the Moon. Here's
where things get a little bit funny.
Johnny Storm meets the rest of the Royal
Family and realizes that he's seen
Medusa as part of the Frightful Four, they're like an
evil version of the Fantastic Four.
So remember, this is issue number 45 when
we're seeing them for the first time.
Medusa appeared in issue number 36 in an
evil team up called the Frightful Four.
I think what probably ended up happening
is Stan Lee liked her character so much
that he wanted to make her an Inhuman but
had to find a way to explain how she
could be in that team
and also be an Inhuman. So the official
explanation became that
she had amnesia quote-unquote while she was
fighting with
the Frightful Four. Stan Lee has a long
history a moving characters around in
terms of, you know, what their stories
are, which teams they belong to.
Sometimes it creates some continuity errors.
Nowadays what Marvel does
is they just create, like,
earth-shattering universe events like
the Battle World stuff that's happening.
So after that first appearance, the
Inhumans just kinda bounced around a
couple different titles
until they get their own title in 1975.
It only ran for about twelve issues.
That trend continued for a little while.
They would just get limited runs from
time to time. So they got another one in 1998,
then a different one in 2000,
then again in 2003
and 2007. So as you can see they've been
kind of like this weird little group of
characters that Marvel brings out every
once in a while
but historically they were never popular
enough to sustain their own ongoing
title like the bigger Marvel characters.
That might change whenever the movie
comes out though. Movie sales always
boost Marvel's comic sales.
After that first Robert Downey Jr.
Iron Man came out, sales of Iron Man comics
shot through the roof. The lore of
Inhumans is really cool too
but like a lot of Stan Lee characters
he introduces the characters first
and then, like, many issues later he'll
flesh out their backstory.
Originally their backstory was tied to
the Kree-Skrull war.
The Kree were looking for a weapon to
use against the Skrull so they spent
millennia genetically tampering with humans on Earth. Eventually they abandoned the project
after a prophecy predicted that an
Inhuman would rise and destroy the
Supreme Intelligence
who failed to appear in the Guardains of the Galaxy movie. I know we're all hoping to see
more Kree in Guardians of the Galaxy Two but
it's not confirmed. So while all this Kree-Skrull
war stuff was going on the Inhumans overtime
developed their own internal society. The
biggest part of their culture
was based on genetic engineering in this
rigid caste structure.
It dictated what jobs you could have,
who you could marry, so naturally by design the most powerful Inhumans were members of the Royal Family
and they are very xenophobic which is
why even after the Kree abandoned them they
continued to keep their city hidden.
Black Bolt is a member the Illuminati and
appears in the Avengers a lot but
Crystal has historically been their
biggest ambassador in terms of crossover characters.
She's been a member of Fantastic Four
and she was a member of the Avengers for a long time,
Medusa to a lesser extent too. There was, like, a
very Romeo and Juliet thing going on
with Johnny Storm and Crystal for a
long time so that was like a way
to bridge their cultures in the comics.
For the most part they are allies with
the heroes of Earth but they still have their own agenda
I mean it's like Namor and Black Panther,
they both serve with the Illuminati
but their first priority is always to
their own people. So let's move into Terrigenesis,
that is the foundation for their society
and the process by which they activate their powers.
So taking in the Mists and getting powers
isn't what makes someone an Inhuman,
that's something that's passed down
through genetics. So there are
Inhumans walking around that have not
taken in the Mist, that don't have special powers.
But in order to take advantage of the
Mist you do have to have those
Inhuman genetic markers. The TV show
kind of explored this
where, like, Skye, Trip, and Raina all took
in the Mist but Trip did not have
Inhuman DNA so it killed him
and gave powers to Skye and Raina. The TV
show's really simplified the process by which
Terrigenesis happens, you know, and how
they find these other Inhuman people.
They've kind of tied it to the Kree but I
don't know how much they're gonna
explain that because
the Kree are largely a group that show up
in the Guardians of the Galaxy movies
so they might keep them there. Most of
what we see on the TV show
is just gonna focus on the Inhumans
living on Earth in secret groups.
So I'm not expecting to see Attilan or any
of the Royal Family.
What I'm hoping is is that they weave
the idea of the Inhumans living on Earth
into Age of Ultron, Civil War,
and the rest the movies, obviously
building up to the actual Inhumans movie.
Nothing's been confirmed but I know
there are a lot of questions about Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver's powers.
As far as we know right now their powers
flow from the Mind Gem
so they're slightly different from the
Inhumans so I'm not gonna call them Inhumans.
They have confirmed a few Inhuman
characters that they've cast for Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
already, they're minor characters.
There are some people that appear in the
comics but I'm just gonna wait for them to
appear in episodes before I talk about
them. So like tonight if we meet any new
characters I'll just explain that in my episode video.
There's all kinds of cool stuff that we
could talk about like the relationships
within the Royal Family like
Black Bolt's evil brother Maximus the Mad. He has a
son with Medusa named
Ahura. Just in general, Marvel, gonna
save all the best stuff for the movies.
That's not coming out till July 2019,
I know that's a long way off.
The interesting thing is that that
movie is coming out after
Infinity War Part 2 which I think is kinda weird. So
Inhumans is, right now, the last movie in Phase 3.
So here's my big question for you guys,
which Inhumans from the comics do you wanna see
on the TV show? I know, we're all hoping for
the Kamala Khan Ms. Marvel but I don't
think that's gonna happen.
Right now they're really pushing Skye and
Raina as the two main characters.
They're like two sides of the same coin.
Raina, who spent her entire life trying to
become her true self,
learn about her heritage, and Skye who wants
absolutely nothing to do with it.
So now, like, you have two characters
that are going to be exploring their new powers
and their relationship to their people. That's like the main story for the second half of the season,
exploring the culture of the Inhumans and
watching them develop their powers.
The interesting thing about Raina is
that she got what she wanted
but because her transformation
physically altered her so much
she's gonna wind up in this Mystique
type situation, like Mystique from X-Men.
People will probably look down on her
appearence as a deformity
so for her it's like an evil genie
situation. Your wish was granted
but what you got isn't exactly what you
asked for. So don't forget, new epsidoes
start tonight. Be sure to subscribe to get it,
I'll post it after the episode airs. And
there is a new Avengers trailer coming
on Thursday so I'll do a new break down video for that.
I'll probably do another bonus Avengers video
too. While you guys wait for all that to drop,
you can click here to catch up with all my
Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. videos from the
midseason finale last year
and you can click here to learn about a
maybe Spider-Man post credits scene in Avengers.
They're just, Danny Elfman is just composing some
music for it so we might see, like, a
teaser but I don't think they've cast the
actor yet.
Thank you so much for watching, I'll see you guys
tonight. Now let's all do thing.